Perla has barely slept this week running
on adrenaline she and her friends are
blocking roads in downtown Beirut to
keep the pressure on the government
so long but it elevated so fast in the
last agreements the protests that have
erupted all across Lebanon have not come
from nowhere this has been building for
years we have seen over the past years
recurrent protests people getting really
angry about but all these manifestations
of state failure you know garbage
electricity what-have-you
it's very clear that that that this
country is managed very poorly and
people and people pay taxes and they see
nothing in return
Karla explains what that feels like
because so we were running fighting for
survival every day like it's my day I
was a survival mine then they started
the week we have those a problem with
the week the bread was gonna be cut off
the 2015 garbage crisis was another
turning point
politicians bickered over who would
collect it off the streets fueled by
their business interests resulting in
the country drowning under piles of
garbage it triggered demonstrations then
- the same message is coming from
everyone out protesting now whether
Sunni Shia Druze or Christian their
leaders have become rich at their and
Lebanon's expense that unity in a
society that is defined by its sectarian
allegiances is a first Carla is not
alone when she accuses Lebanon's leaders
of exploiting sectarianism to keep the
people divided religion leaders are all
over the politics
from here on I was taking from Saudi I
was taking from France what it's leaking
from the state whereas more than as a
fine if they took in Liberty Square
country these protests may have been
triggered by a proposed tax on using
social media apps to make phone calls
but before that a large part of the
population was already at a boiling
point
most recently forest fires spread across
Lebanon the government couldn't control
them it's fire aircraft in disrepair it
had to seek help from abroad peddlers is
just one voice among many governments
have come and gone and their failures
have piled up to become unbearable but
the leaders who govern this country have
remained the same for decades and the
people want accountability Stephanie
Decker al Jazeera beaut